i'll tell you what else is really
interesting too in this whole debacle
there's another level to this those who
are algorithmically fed red-pilled type
information countering the narrative and
those who are
actually engaged with the content in
general
what happens is there are a lot of
people so i was talking to some guy i
know today
and he said he's like listen man you
used to be really good at everything and
now all you do is just basically you're
like a hardcore trump supporter and it's
all you do is just always always always
protecting trump
and i was like do you watch my show and
i was like because
we do defend him we do criticize him
he's like i only ever see from you
defending trump and i said have you
considered
that facebook and youtube are only
giving you the videos i produce
out of the you know three and a half
hours per day that i produce
they're only showing you the trump
article the you know the trump
defense ones and you're they're ignoring
the times we've talked about him when we
we you know we're critical of him on war
and john bolton and things like that
it's like i think
i think we said john bolton 5 000 times
and criticized trump for hiring a bunch
of dumb people
certainly we defended him and i did vote
for him that's true but there's a lot of
people who were trump supporters
who only ever got from youtube the
videos that were like
trump isn't that bad and then the times
when i was like here's what i don't like
about trump and here's what i'm mad
about it doesn't go to them
because they're less likely to click it
so youtube isn't incentivized to share
those videos
then you'll get people on the left who
are only fed that content because it's
more likely to be watched by trump
supporters
and then they're like this is all he
produces but then the people who
actually engage with the content who
would watch every episode
i see them commenting on commenting
online and they're like we're talking
about he like
criticizes them all the time especially
ian you know he's like when luke and
dave smith on the show was like a two
hours of just nothing but ragging on
trump
awesome but people don't get there for
that show because the algorithm doesn't
give it to him
trump has a lot to be react not to take
too far away from what you're saying but
all these people have enough to be
critical about i think i mean sure you
and
this was actually one of the points that
i raised as one of the main reasons i
voted for trump
was because the media is like
relentlessly like totally
actually unfairly critical of trump
constantly
and they were at the time covering up
the hunter biden laptop story it's like
there's no evidence they're going to be
critical of biden they're actually
covering up a story that's critical of
biden right now
and i was like if the media i mean the
media's function the point
of a free press is to be able to
criticize power
in a free country yep and if that's not
happening by whatever set of
you know for whatever set of reasons
then you have to become skeptical of the
side that benefits from that
and that was part of the reason that i
wanted to vote for trump seems like a
symbiotic reason like
the clicks like you were saying you it's
a click bait thing so they're making
money
off of it and it's also politically
infusive for this liberal economic order
basically well right plus the i think
tim was describing that
there's a there's an echo chamber aspect
to the algorithm the algorithm gets
better and better and better it's
driven by machine learning so it gets
better and better and better at
predicting what kinds of things you will
click on and therefore play
the first five seconds of an ad of that
they make some fraction of a penny off
of
unless you accidentally click on the ad
and then they make some slightly more
fraction of a penny accidentally click
on it
i mean has anybody ever actually clicked
one of those things on my list
i click on ads on instagram oh yeah
instagram's dangerous
dude there's there's cool stuff there
was one where it was like a mini
lightsaber
all i can tell you that it was a torch
but it was had like a like a
like it was awesome all i can tell you
then is that your algorithms get are
getting to know you very well
dude they showed me this solar torch
thing it's called whatever and it's got
like a jet like super long
and he like melts through a tin can and
i was like i have to buy that
that is sort of a seriously man toy that
yeah i know every man does need like
could you send me that ad
actually yeah no there is one here but
literally i was just like i can get a
torch faster so i just went and bought a
torch
yeah i was like cool and then we like we
have fires in the back sometimes i was
like i'll just use the torch
yeah no that's fun but no the the truth
is though that the
the whole point is that the algorithm's
supposed to learn
what you'll click on because it drives
their ad revenues
there doesn't have to be a nefarious
plot you don't have to have you know
whoever the directors of youtube and
these shadowy rooms
saying oh we're going to turn this all
left all left all off it doesn't have to
be that
these algorithms are going to feed
people echo chambers and that's how you
end up getting like conspiracy theories
like whether it's q and on or blue and
on or whatever and on or
whale anon i made up on twitter whaling
on oh that was when twitter you know
they made that was a bird bird watcher
thing
you know i don't know if it still exists
but they made the
like fake news is everywhere on twitter
and they put you know a sample fake
tweet and it said whales
whales are not real they're robots paid
for by the government to control you and
i was like this is wailing on and so i'm
like making memes like
they look like a cue and as there's a
whale though with the tail it's like
so so here's what happens there was a
study a few years ago where
they tracked various networks on twitter
and then created a visualization i saw
that
they found that digital marketing
overlaps with the resistance the
establishment democratic position
that means the what is that hashtag
the resistance yeah right right right
yeah so what happens is
pepsi and coke and oreo and whatever big
brands nabisco
their ad campaigns live in the same
universe
as anti-trump democrats so their
advertisings are crap are crafted around
this core group of individuals
which means if they see a video where
someone's sitting there like with their
eyes half closed and they go
i like donald trump they go get our ads
off that video
and then google says okay okay okay and
then google is we just lost
a 50 million dollar contract what
happened the guy said he likes trump
okay we'll ban it ban it we're losing 50
million dollars
yeah there it is yep there it is i can
tell you something a little scarier than
that i happen to know
some people who work in you know ai
development and all of this
and so this guy called me a while back
and he's like kind of big into all this
he's like a phd in it or whatever
and he's like yeah i don't know if you
know that they're actually
you know you have machine learning or
whatever the algorithms and how they
work
they actually the people who are behind
that
deci you know you have to with the
machine learning algorithm is like the
the machine makes a guess and then
humans are training it by saying i was a
good guess or a bad guess right and many
not always but in a lot of cases
and they're literally using
intersectionality as the guide
to decide what the right and wrong
answers are and so it's like you know oh
was this white supremacy
you know it's intersectionality is how
they're using to decide that kind of
stuff
and that's what's that's what's getting
baked into those algorithms
meanwhile they publish articles with the
iron law of bloke projection saying
white supremacy is on all of the
algorithms we have to put more
intersectionality into the algorithms
a few a few years ago i was hanging out
with you and and helen pluck rose and
peter pagosian
and i got an argument with uh with peter
no that's not a surprise
and it was because i was saying that the
media was creating this
the it was it was social media
algorithms and he was adamant that was
coming from the universities
i think both both are true both are true
but the point i made was
this i wat i literally watched this
happen i experienced this i started
working for
uh i started working in digital media
spaces
end of 2011. i officially started
working for vice in 2013.
i went to disney i watched how they
implemented these things why they wanted
to do it they explained it to me
and explained to them why they were
wrong but what happened was it's very
very simple
it's a simple algorithmic equation when
facebook started rising in prominence in
attention and generating ad revenue they
started to notice that police brutality
videos were skyrocketing in viewership
something about it was just getting more
shares and more attention
and there's like a viral song this is
what happens when you call the cops
there were websites dedicated to nothing
but police brutality videos in the
in the alexa top 500 absolutely crazy
all they would do
is just aggregate police brutality
videos now sidetrack
i'm sure a lot of young people who are
swimming in that
are now active as saying defund the
police because they their whole brains
were matched by it but
something else happened if you made a
post and said
police brutality the algorithm
recognized people love
this stuff send it to him more but then
something else happened there were also
videos about social justice
racism sexism the algorithm also said
man people love these videos
send it to everyone and then something
magical happened
racism skyrocketing police brutality
skyrocketing and then all sudden someone
made
racist police brutality and then where
if a racism video would get x views and
a police brutality video would get wide
views
a racism a police brutality and racism
segment
would get x y views well i should say x
plus y because i don't want to assume
it's exponential or x y minus 20
or some algorithm of it would be an
increase
and so this created a space when digital
news outlets started getting tons of
venture capital
funding they started to realize this is
how you make money
a good example uh is there's an exposan
mike.com are you from you're familiar
with mike.com yeah
it still exists right um when they
started
they were libertarian they were ron paul
libertarian apparently
so it's been reported and it was because
ron paul was very popular online the the
ron paul loved revolution so they were
like okay let's write these articles
then they started to play that game at
least it's been reported this if you
want to avoid
litigation but so this is what i read
and i could be wrong but uh my
understanding is that
they started putting out articles on
social justice
and then creating formulas where it was
like uh you know
x has an x problem or x has a y problem
and then all of a sudden
combining these different things was
getting more and more views and traffic
because if you had a community of people
who who watched police brutality in a
community of people who watched social
justice
you mix those communities together and
you maximize your viewership
this pushed intersectionality as the
perfect ideology
all of a sudden we started we there's
one article from vice i can't remember
the exact title
but it was like trans women of color
being beaten by police proves that
the the requirement proves why we need
black lives matter
and it was just like every possible
keyword mashed into a headline
to get as much traffic as possible to
maximize revenue
and so long as advertisers don't mind
being on these psychotic
i mean this is like
when you read these articles like there
was a joke meme where a guy is like
sitting in a room and he's uh trying to
write a name for a
vice article he's trying to come up with
a vice article so he pulls a an adult
toy out of a box and throws it at the
wall
and it just sticks and then he's like
transgender ketamine dealers of colombia
or something just random
that's that's basically what was
happening and then the advertisers are
like
i'm okay with this and so as long as
that system functioned and advertisers
didn't care it was fine
and then they found their boogeyman with
trump we saw
gamergate happen this was i mean the
start of the culture where it's a very
interesting thing and i'm not i can't
get into history mostly because it's
very complicated you know
i think the gamergate was the first
battle but
what i think happened was these video
game websites
what do you write about you have a job
your job is to write five articles per
day
or three articles per day you've already
wrote every walkthrough for
you know the new zelda game what do you
write
no new game coming out until the holiday
season um
speedrunner did a speed run all right uh
oh
video games racist oh yeah and sexist
and anti-gay kkk go away put it all in a
headline and we got a hit article and
then every day they had to do that
and then all of a sudden that's what
gaming became say the sexist thing too
and you put like a picture of like a
bikini anime chick or something like
that
and then like you you're also just
getting guys that are like oh yeah
chicken bikini because even though it's
a cartoon click whoops
you have like a sexist article a racist
article
uh an anti-gay article and then you'd
make the sexist racist anti-gay article
and then those writers would go to other
companies and write an anti-gay article
over there
that would enable them to to you know
so yeah it happened fast too yeah so big
time that's true because people were so
hungry and they desperately want this
confirmation bias and they love
tribalism but what happened is
you'd get one article you know where
this outlet would write some nonsensical
drama about
completely not just total bs video gamer
accused of
you know oh they're uh stealing a
hundred dollars from
their ex and then people would click on
it and they'd be like i can't believe he
really did that and the story nowhere in
it would actually say it actually
happened but then another app would pick
it up and be like i can't believe
so-and-so was accused of doing this
then the next article would say multiple
reports now can
you know citing that this happened and
then loops all the way back around and
they create a circular
feedback loop of sourceless garbage and
the whole
the whole thing is just algorithmically
trying to generate revenue here's the
best part though
they've created this feedback loop where
they're basically parasites
right you know like i think the
conversations we have are
imperfect we're not the best we we
engage in culture war stuff
too and nobody is perfect but i think we
try to have legitimate conversations
really break down these ideas to the
best of our abilities what they do is
they just leech
and parasite so recently we had this
this journalist from axios got a job at
teen vogue as the editor-in-chief right
well the people who work there
wrote a letter trying to get that
editor-in-chief cancelled for
10-year-old tweets
in response it was uh a
seven-figure ad deal was pulled frozen
the article said they lost it and then
it said it was frozen because of the
controversy
so this this company teen vogue which is
supposed to be a fashion magazine and
now it's like writing about marx and
social justice and critical theory
hires on people who are good at writing
about intersectionality because it gets
a lot of clicks
and then those people attack their own
company costing their own company seven
figures
so perhaps there's some optimism in all
of this in that these people are just
consuming themselves and that will
eventually just be a withered husk in
the corner of nothing
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you